in this video I'll be introducing
another algebraic law of sets the
distributive law the distributive law is
simply saying that the set and operation
will be distributed over another set in
operation for instance a intersection B
Union C equals a or section B Union a
intersection C so I thought it might be
helpful to use Venn diagrams for the
conceptual idea of this and then I'll do
a separate video on the actual
definition so if we look at a here and
we separate a and then we decide to
separate B Union C then when we actually
go to find the union or the intersection
of these two regions it's easy to see
that it is this region so hopefully for
the purposes of equality this region
here will match this region here so
let's get right to it we have a
intersection B so we have to set a and
the set B so that means that a
intersection B is going to be this
region here and we have to also find a
intersection C so that's this region and
if we take the union of those two
regions then we're left with all of this
jazz so it looks like they are in fact
equal but to be more rigorous we'll
revisit the actual definition of the
intersection in the unions in the next
video